-Welcome back, everybody!
We are hanging out
with Samuel L. Jackson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We want to talk about
your new Apple TV+ show,
"The Last Days of Ptolemy Grey."
-Mm.
-You had the rights to this
12 years ago?
-Yeah, 10, 12 years, yeah.
-Took you 12 years to make this?
-Well, you know...
I was trying to get
the ordinary people who were
doing, like, streamer --
Well, not streamers,
but series and stuff to do it,
and they were like,
"Well, you know,
let's just see if we can
make a movie out of it."
And they wanted to do it
an hour and a half, two hours.
The book's kind of
too deep to do that.
So I was very resistant,
but I had let them
buy the rights from me,
so I had to wait until
everything went into turnaround
so I could get it back...
-Yeah.
Oh, my God.
-...and get it done
somewhere else.
But, you know, things happen
when they're supposed to,
so in the time of streaming,
it's perfect.
-Yeah.
-So I'm happy.
-How many parts is it?
-Six.
-Six parts.
-So, Friday, there'll be
episode 1 and 2,
and then, every Friday
for the next four weeks,
you'll get the rest of it.
-And what was it about the book
that connected you so much?
-Well, Ptolemy is --
Ptolemy's a 92-, 93-year-old man
who's suffering
from Alzheimer's dementia.
And my grandfather, my mom,
her brother, her sister,
and my father's sister
all had it.
-Oof.
-So, I kind of watched the light
go out in a lot
of people's eyes.
And the story is beautiful.
And this guy is isolated.
The kid that takes care of him
gets killed in a drive-by.
That's not a big secret,
that's not a plot divulge.
And he's by himself until this
17-year-old girl happens to --
-Who is amazing.
Dominique Fishback.
-Dominique Fishback
happens to come by.
And they end up having
this beautiful relationship,
where she's been taking care of
her mom, who was an addict
for a long time, who died.
And she's never had really love
or been able to act like a kid.
He has a doctor's appointment
she takes him to,
where this guy proposes to him,
"I have this drug
that will allow you to be clear
for a specific amount of time,
and then it's gonna kill you.
But it's up to you
to make up your mind
if you're gonna take it."
So you're asking a dude
with dementia,
does he want to take a drug.
You know, she's like,
"How's that work?"
And he has to make that choice.
And it's, you know,
you follow --
you go back in his life
and see a life well-lived.
-It's well done...
-And, you know, totally cool.
-...and it's beautiful,
and it's very, very cool.
-Yeah, nice little mystery
in there.
-Yeah, exactly right.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Samuel L. Jackson in
"The Last Days of Ptolemy Grey."
Take a look at this.
-That in there ain't right.
-Oh, well, stop -- stop --
stop doing what you're doing
and go close that door.
-No, no, no, no.
You listen!
That's don't get dealt with,
I'mma be haunted.
You understand?
Haunted.
-Mnh, mnh, mnh.
-Mm-hmm.
So where your cleaning stuff at?
-My treasures.
Unh-unh, unh-unh.
-What are you talking about?
-Every time Reggie said he gonna
clean up here and here,
he end up throwing away all --
all my best things.
My best things!
-Oh, yeah? Like what?
-[ Stammers ]
[ Groans ]
-Oh, come on.
Don't do that.
Come on.
I'll show you.
-Oh, you're moving too fast!
-Oh, I'm sorry.
Here, sit, sit.
Sorry.
-[ Panting ]
-I'll tell you what.
I'll show you everything
before I toss it.
You get to decide.
-Huh?
-You like that?
-Uh, uh...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah,
you like that.
-Yeah, that's right.
Samuel L. Jackson, everybody.
"The Last Days of Ptolemy Grey"
begins streaming this Friday
on Apple TV+.